hello and welcome to this video plane I
am zxcv be not so good never give tapex
okay dokay so I won't give you any take
backs um so what's the deal here I'm
trying a new line here against the
exchange that recently got recommended
to me so let's give it a try the only
critical move as as usual 9085 if black
doesn't defend the pot why should
usually take it yeah we'll probably see
what the idea is because he will take it
I guess otherwise it's totally
unpredictable playable option but
doesn't scab like very much so what to
do here move the Queen then Castle long
or move the bishop I can actually go to
see one I just regular recognized this
idea not sure about it it looks a bit
strange but seems playable
you
going to f5 ok maybe rocky 8 asking this
d Rock immediately what it wants to do
Jack idea is that the key now is able to
defend the Seaport after later Bishop f4
yeah those endings are quite solid him I
mean they're Jewish yeah it's quite
often a medal yet trying to propose some
problems two to maybe get some some more
interesting play without being too hit
too ambitious which happens to me quite
often in those blitz games I try to do
something with black when there is
nothing to do and you should rather just
play something normal and make it wrong
okay we'll see what happens one thing
that irritates me a bit is that whenever
I move the night this is possibly 95 95
now I can take and pretty okay with that
hmm not sure how to untangle him okay
I'll play a pass move
Jim if okay f4 Weiss why is he going for
F for now I can go at five my fear was
that after f5 instead of f6 that he can
take up to 95 looking at this is seven
point which is not possible anymore now
yeah it should be okay for black I hope
you five is definitely okay for me
that's an interesting tribe okay and I
cannot play night f5 here unfortunately
you might have f5 here whoa f5 Bishop
f7f six looks a little bit like a
position out of the Berlin Wall and it
has opened up already which is nice so I
just have to withstand this there's a
tacky if if I do my position is very
okay
we take on g7 and then Bishop f6
something like that this is probably
equal
whoa what's the deal
try to push this bag not easy to get to
the pawn though maybe this forked is 70
this is a dl this is something I can do
okay that's not doing anything against
it if you trade the rook I'm just better
yeah now i should be able to win that
point let's see how to do it night 26
probably this a night to c4 is a good
idea then I have Bishop t5 hmm okay oh
what's that taking I guess taking a
skirt now let's see any to distract the
night and yeah but it dont diss push up
this is a hard time to regroup that it
actually attacks the pawn I can take
Bishop d6 but then after Bishop e5 you
will go f7 this is not good anyway white
still has a hard time to do anything
here g5
hmm
time morning I don't really get around
to that if 5 squared ah I heard no just
no didn't get around to it anyway
probably have to do this okay now i can
take this take 25 but probably not
having a winning position it's closed
it's closed yeah this point is almost
lost but I don't see how I can get it
Bishop t65 doesn't work he always says
f7 okay maybe in that moment I just
dropped back this may be possible then I
still get it right this and they just
drop back I can also try to put the
bishop on h6 see if he's not careful and
for Bishop see one we have no time
absolutely no time what's he doing now
now he's got a connection issues when
will be down two seconds
white forfeits on time huh probably King
c5 is a draw yeah not sure I could have
I could have done um just like this this
and this now if seven I drop back and
and to take it next probably silly draw
but it's difficult to press something
out of those endings I think and still
surprised that I'm not just winning flat
out from here because the F part looks
like it should drop but maybe it doesn't
the engine wants to play Bishop d6 now
yeah this might be okay to win the porn
but I didn't want to go to opposite
colored bishops yeah maybe this is
really just not enough to win computer
wants to do this probably intending to
come around like that maybe this one I
played in a somewhat simple manner maybe
it was too simple oh I have king at five
haha I didn't look at that at all no
it's embarrassing King f5 I'm ah a lot
better than in the game whoa yeah now he
doesn't come to have for it was a big
big opportunity yeah I think an
interesting moment was around here when
he decided to play a for which I found
surprising i was rather thinking of f3
or be three those typical moves and
white plays in the supposition and I
thought here should be in pretty decent
shape but it's probably not more than
that it just kind of okay equal ish
the engine just takes this pawn I didn't
consider the world because Ruby eight
looks so scary check that you stuck on
the back rank but probably there is
nothing happening yeah if the night
moves I just go g5 huh yeah okay I mean
this is possible and probably will lead
to some kind of a draw ending okay so it
was a window on time probably a draw
would have been appropriate but yeah
okay I also saw no reason to take the
draw and like us the only one at least
having some chances okay well thanks for
watching